JOANNA SMITH: Let's
start with Gus.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
So we're going to talk today
about some features of the
Google+ mobile platform.
And these are really timely
right now because just last
week there was the release of
the Google Play services.
And this lit up these platform
features for
Google+ within Android.
And so the three features we're
going to highlight today
are the +1, and the share, and
then Sign In with Google+.
So Chirag, do you want to tell
a little bit more on how this
gets incorporated?
CHIRAG SHAH: Thank you, Gus.
So the Google+ Android SDK
actually lives inside Google
Play services.
Google Play services is a
platform that lives right next
to Google Play.
This means that it is deployed
to all Android devices that
are Froyo and up and that
contain Google Play on it.
JOANNA SMITH: Chirag, when you
say is deployed, do you mean
it's already been deployed,
or it will be?
CHIRAG SHAH: It has already
been deployed.
JOANNA SMITH: And users don't
have to do anything to update
it themselves?
It's just there and
it's ready to go?
CHIRAG SHAH: That is correct.
So you as a developer can assume
that the device already
has Google Play services on it
if it is Froyo and higher, and
has Google Play installed.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
CHIRAG SHAH: So what does
this mean for you?
This means that your APKs are
much smaller when integrating
with Google+.
So practically, this means all
of the +1 button assets and
images live inside Google
Play services.
And all of the functionality,
regarding +1-ing and signing
the user in, lives inside
Google Play services.
And you as a developer just
need to worry about
integrating the components
into your application.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
So let's talk about share.
So here's an example
of someone doing a
share from an app.
So the first thing that happens
is that they click the
button that will actually
trigger the share.
And then they get a form that's
pre-populated with the
text that will be shared.
And then they can select the
circles and the people that
they want to share with.
And then finally, after they
click Share, then the share
will happen with the content
that they populated the Share
interaction with.
And there will also be an
annotation from the app.
So Chirag will tell you how
this works out in code.
CHIRAG SHAH: So basically, the
simplest way you can integrate
the Share button in your
application is by adding a
simple button.
In the example Gus showed you
earlier, we invoke the Share
through a list item.
So you can integrate the share
functionality anywhere in your
application.
So for this example, we're going
to have a simple button
incorporated from the Android
SDK, and we're going to have
simple text saying
Share on Google+.
Next we're going to find the
simple share button from your
layout, and set its onClick
handler to invoke the Google+
Share dialogue.
So let's deconstruct what's
going on in this sample code.
First you build a shareIntent
using the shareCompat library.
This library makes it easier for
you to build shareIntents
and include rich media for users
to share on Google+.
Here in this example, I
pass text and a URL
in the setText method.
Next, I used the setType method
to identify the type of
content we're sharing
as text slash plain.
Finally we call the getIntent
method to get the intent we've
built with the shareCompat
library.
And finally, we call the
setPackage method on the
intent we've obtained.
And we tell it to specify
the Google+ application.
And this means that once the
intent is launched, it will
directly open the Google+
Share dialog.
JOANNA SMITH: Now Chirag,
forgive me if I'm wrong, but
Share isn't exactly a
new feature, right?
That's been around since the
very beginning of G+, right?
CHIRAG SHAH: Yeah,
that is correct.
So here we're launching an
attempt to open the Google+
application.
And the Google+ application is
responsible for launching the
Share dialogue.
And you, as a developer, can
pre-fill the type of text and
URLs that are pre-populated
in the Share dialogue.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, so if a
developer has already
integrated this share experience
into their app, now
that we've added Google Play
services, will anything be
affected, or do they need
to make any changes?
CHIRAG SHAH: That is correct.
So you won't need to
make any changes.
So if you want to add Google
Play services, you can get new
features, such as the +1 button
and Sign In button.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
Good to know.
Thank you.
GUS CLASS: Speaking of
new features, here's
the mobile +1 button.
Here's an example of the
+1 button in the wild.
And what you can see in this
example is you can see that
you and Julia Ferraioli have
+1'd this item inside of the
Google store.
And so Chirag will tell you
about how you can incorporate
this functionality into
your own apps.
CHIRAG SHAH: So all you need to
do is include the +1 button
in your Android layout.
Here the attributes should
look very similar to you
because it inherits from
a standard button.
So you can control the
layout width, height.
But you can also declare the
plus size attribute to declare
the type of--
to declare the appearance
of the +1 button.
And this size attribute is very
similar to what you'll
see on the web.
We have the small, standard,
medium, tall.
Next, you'll initialize
the +1 button in
your onCreate handler.
Here, you'll call the initialize
method and pass in
the URL that should be +1'd.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, so we have a
button-o-matic, basically,
that generates all the code
for you for your web.
Do we have anything similar
for mobile?
CHIRAG SHAH: So we don't
have a o-matic, per
se, for the +1 button--
for the native +1 button
on Android.
But the appearance demonstrated
through the
+1-o-matic is very similar to
the appearance of the +1
button on Android.
For instance, the tall size will
be very similar on native
versus the web.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, so--
CHIRAG SHAH: That's
a great question.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, so I don't
have to go film any new
videos, right?
We're good on that front?
Good to know, good to know.
GUS CLASS: OK, so
let's look at an
implementation of the activity.
So this is actually a
full implementation.
Chirag will actually break
it down into the
important parts for you.
CHIRAG SHAH: So Gus showed you
what your activity will look
like once you integrate
the full--
you fully integrate
the +1 button.
But let's deconstruct what's
going on there.
So in your onCreate handler--
you will first initialize the
PlusClient object and
initialize the +1 button.
And as you can see when we're
+1'ing, or when we're
initializing a +1 button, we'll
pass in the URL that
should be +1'd.
Next we'll integrate the
PlusClient object in the life
cycle of your Android
activity.
So in your onStart handler,
you'll call
PlusClient.connect.
This will start to establish a
connection between your third
party application and Google
Play services.
So your third party application
can start to
connect to the resources in
Google Play services, and get
the assets for the correct size
of the +1 button you've
integrated.
But also control the
functionality of the +1 button
you've integrated in
your application.
And finally, in your onStop
handler, you'll call
PlusClient.disconnect.
And this will terminate the
connection between your
application and Google
Play services.
And this is a best practice
because it will reduce the
number of resources incurred
on the device when it's not
being used.
JOANNA SMITH: All right, so we
just went through a lot of
different steps.
Is there somewhere online where
people can find this
information so they don't have
to keep pausing the video and
writing down all the code?
CHIRAG SHAH: That's
a great point.
You don't need to take notes.
Put down your pencils.
You can visit developers.googl
e.com/plus/mobile.
And from there, you'll find a
beautiful getting started
guide and a sample application
that you can
follow along with.
And the sample application will
look very similar to what
we're covering here
in the slides.
GUS CLASS: Thanks, Chirag.
So the last thing we're going
to talk about today is going
to be Sign In with Google+.
And so here's another
example flow.
Now, a user clicks a Sign In
button and then they're
presented with a list
of their accounts on
their Android device.
After they select an account,
they don't have to enter their
mobile password again because
it's saved and
secure on their device.
And then finally, after
they're signed in, the
application can open, and
some information can
be pulled from Google+.
So Chirag will actually go--
Chirag will go into the
integration steps
for the Sign In button.
CHIRAG SHAH: So integrating
the Sign In button is very
similar to integrating
the +1 button.
But you'll also include the
GET_ACCOUNTS permission in
your AndroidManifest file.
This will allow your third party
application to obtain
the list of accounts
on the device.
Next you'll add the
PlusSignInButton to your layout.
And again, this inherits from a
standard button, so the look
and feel of the interface should
look very familiar.
GUS CLASS: So here's actually
a full implementation of the
Plus Sign In button.
Don't freak out.
Chirag will actually break down
the important pieces of
this code so it's easier
for you to understand.
CHIRAG SHAH: So the first
important thing you'll do is
sign the user in.
And again, you will integrate
the PlusClient object in the
life cycle of your
Android activity.
So when your onStart handler
is invoked, you'll call
PlusClient.connect.
But now in this case, two
things can happen when
PlusClient is invoked.
Google Play services can
go in and invoke your
onConnectionFailed handler, or
your onConnected handler.
Next, you will invoke--
next, you'll implement
your onStop handler.
And again, you'll call
PlusClient.disconnect to
terminate the connection between
your application and
Google Play services.
So as I mentioned before, either
onConnected is invoked
from Google Play services, or
onConnectionFailed is involved
from Google Play services.
onConnected is analogous to
the user being signed in.
And when that method is invoked,
you can update your
user interface to reflect that
the user is signed in.
If the user is not signed in,
your onConnectionFailed
handler will be invoked.
And with that, the Google Play
services will pass in a
connection result.
You'll hang on to this
connection result, and you'll
resolve it when the user presses
the Sign In button.
Now we save ConnectionResult
as a member
variable in our activity.
And when the user presses the
Sign In button, our onClick
handler will be invoked,
and we'll call--
we'll start resolving the
connection result we saved in
the member variable.
And here we call
mConnectionResul
t.startResolutionForResult.
And we pass in a request code,
so we can get a handle on it
once a response comes back.
So now let's look at the
onActivityResult handler.
Whenever the activity comes
back, we'll capture the
request code and we'll see
if it worked out OK.
If the resolution worked out
correctly, we'll call
PlusClient again and complete
the signing in of the user.
JOANNA SMITH: Now wait.
So because this is all using
Google Play services, which
lives inside of the Android--
or the Android SDK lives
inside of Google Play
services, they can do all this
without including any of
Google Play services in
their own ADK, right?
CHIRAG SHAH: That is
slightly true.
All of the complicated logic of
Google Play services, and
all of the image assets of the
+1 button and Sign In button
will live on the device, but
you'll include a lightweight
jar to start establishing a
connection between your
application and Google
Play services.
So you can obtain that jar from
the Google Android SD--
from the Android SDK manager.
And it's a very lightweight jar
that simply connects to
Google Play services.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, that
makes sense then.
GUS CLASS: Great.
So that's pretty much all we
have to talk to you guys today
about for updates for Google+
for mobile developers.
As always, remember you can
get all the resources that
we've talked about from
the Google Developer
documentation.
And you can also ask questions
on our Google+ page.
And we'll try to get to them
in these office hours.
And we can also try to get to
them independently of this if
you guys have questions
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
So I'm going to monitor for the
next few minutes while we
continue to talk.
But if you think of anything
later, if you're watching the
YouTube video, we'll try to
check back fairly regularly in
the next few days to see if
we can help you out again.
In the meantime, so, Lee, you've
been listening with
rapt attention for
this whole thing.
Do you have any comments or
questions or just insights
into what we've been talking
about today?
LEE DENISON: So one question I
have for you, Chirag, is now,
with Google Play Services
being deployed to these
Android devices, you said
earlier that when I embed a
Share button into my
application, it uses the share
dialog from the Plus
application.
Do users still need to have the
Plus application installed
for me to be able to do that?
CHIRAG SHAH: Yeah,
that is correct.
So the user will need to have
the Google+ Android
application installed on their
device for the Share dialogue
to prompt up.
And in Google Play services, we
offer a helper utility to
check if the Google+ application
is installed.
If it is installed, you can
continue and create your
shareIntent using the
shareCompat library, and
launch the Share dialogue.
But if the user does not have
the Google+ application
installed, they can go out to
the market and install it, and
then go back and resume
sharing the content
they want to share.
So that's a good question.
JOANNA SMITH: And Gus, I know
that we first surfaced some of
this documentation at Google
I/O this year, and then we
went into developer preview.
So what does it mean for
developers now that we're out
of the developer
preview phase?
What does that mean for
these features?
GUS CLASS: One second.
I have to cough.
[COUGHS]
JOANNA SMITH: Not allowed.
GUS CLASS: But yeah, so the
big difference between the
functionality that we announced
at I/O and today is
that at I/O, the Google Play
services had not been out yet.
And so this functionality, we
knew that it was going to be
coming, and so we had that
developer preview.
But now that Google Play
services is out, all of this
is lit up on devices,
and so the
functionality is available.
JOANNA SMITH: And so anybody,
regardless of the preview
group, is now able to develop
with it, and with the full
access to the Google
Play services?
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
So now, within your apps, that
functionality like the +1
button is available.
And up until this release
last week, it was not
possible to do this.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, that's
good to know.
Lee, anything else
while we wait?
LEE DENISON: One other question
I did have actually,
is if you use a Sign In button,
and you would like, in
your application, to maybe
at some critical point
re-authenticate the user,
is that possible?
CHIRAG SHAH: So once the user
signs in, they've identified
themselves with the
application.
In the application, it's
effectively single sign-on.
So the onConnected method will
re-trigger if you rotate the
device, or you put the activity
to sleep for a
certain amount of time, the
activity will resume and will
call connect again, and
onConnected will be invoked,
and the user is authenticated.
So the only thing--
if you swap users
on the device.
Like if I sign out--
if I remove my Gmail account on
my device, and add Gus on
it, he would have to re-identify
himself to the
application.
And then once he returns
it back, I'd
add my accounts back.
LEE DENISON: Cool.
Thanks.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
So slightly off-topic, we
actually had a question posted
on the GL event on Google+
a while ago.
And this person wants to
ask about Hangouts.
And they didn't know how to get
their app started, so I
directed them to our forum
so that they could start
looking into that.
But one question that seems to
be at the core of this that I
think it's worth at least
discussing is, they want to
know about integrating
Google+ Hangouts
directly into their site.
Now maybe you can illustrate why
now this is possible with
the current API, or any insight
you have into how this
might be done.
Because I don't-- as far as I
know-- and I'm new-- but I
don't think that it's
actually possible at
this point in time.
Is that correct?
CHIRAG SHAH: Yeah,
that is correct.
You can't integrate a Hangout
within your application.
But you can add the Hangouts
button to invoke a Hangout
into a new window.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, so it still
launches from Google+, but the
button lives on your own site.
CHIRAG SHAH: Yeah, you can use
the Simple Hangout button.
And it will create a
new window, or it
will open a new tab.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, cool, so
Jeremy, I hope this helps you
get started, at least
with where to look.
And as always, please
post in our forum.
We don't really know how to help
you with implementation
details, but we would hopefully
like to see other
people helping you out, and
help you find all the
information you need.
I'm not seeing any other
comments appearing on our
YouTube page.
[LAUGHS]
One person comments on our G+
event that they would like a
suggestion for Google+ where you
can join a streaming event
from a Nexus tablet.
So they're looking for mobile
support for joining a
streaming event.
We'll work on that.
In the meantime, we're going to
post this on YouTube after
we finish recording.
So you can always go back and
watch it after the fact.
So anyone else have
anything to say?
LEE DENISON: Not for me.
JOANNA SMITH: All right.
Well then I have, actually, an
announcement about Hangouts,
which is that version 1.3
was just released.
This is really exciting, because
it has a normalizing
feature, which is where you
can mirror yourself.
So let's say, I go
into a Hangout.
And my face comes up as I'm
prepping and primping to make
sure I look cute enough in my
pajamas to talk to my sister.
But I look weird, because
I'm backwards.
And I don't like that
flopped image.
So now I can mirror it.
And it doesn't mirror
for my sister.
It just mirrors for myself so
that I look normal to me as
well as normal to her.
And I think this is a really
great feature for perspective.
And I really like playing
with it too.
So I encourage you to play with
1.3 and start playing
with that yourself.
And one last check
at our comments.
And I'm not seeing anything,
so at the request of our
visiting guest, I'm going to
make a really bad pun.
And then we're going
to say goodbye.
So, how do you get holy water?
Anyone?
GUS CLASS: How do you do it?
JOANNA SMITH: You boil
the hell out of it.
[WEAK LAUGHTER]
GUS CLASS: Thanks, everyone.
JOANNA SMITH: Bye.
GUS CLASS: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]